welcome to this video pure chappy with
that name but it's a grandmaster yeah
play some kind of yet shuttle system go
be three next this is not a very popular
set up against this ready style thing
okay with a five-mail it's a bit more
interesting I have not played before tho
thought you would play for me I'd like
to prevent me from going before okay
well this is good for white at least
then should be enough for a small
advantage let's see Roxy one or single
95 already or Quincy tool I don't know
sometimes tricky to determine what the
best move or is
okay let's set up that battery
this is a better confirmation then with
me playing before and I'm really
questioning a little bit if I could have
managed to get that in earlier maybe it
was possible which I didn't really see
how
mmm what is he doing here I mean I mean
I don't need to play Queen be too i
guess maybe I need to I would like to
play rook c2 and double here
yeah that was an idea I'm trying to
really and kick my night away now
f6
okay let's do it now I need to prevent
you five like f 6 9 movie 5 oh wow
didn't see that one coming price is
working at all and takes 90 x okay this
is probably really okay but I can take
on c5 ride instead okay let's do it i
have to play it anyway so no use and
pretending that i'm thinking about it
okay i cannot take here so i have to
take this now officially to know what
them take it to maybe now no okay really
surprising and then what is this point
he wants to invade now look here maybe
924 C 1 Quincy three and maybe maybe
he's just quick enough maybe but ok man
this is pretty pretty well protected and
I have queen before maybe I go there
immediately I have Bishop h three things
like that I mean this is relatively well
coordinated it's not that bad check
yeah let's open up this thing check here
and then you will kick with then you
apply Queenie six I can take 90 form for
night c4 maybe or it says something
better okay I have to do this probably
anyway whoa really night age for you can
allow that check neither five but then
is invading ok ok ok ok I shouldn't have
played knowledge for in the first place
maybe I need to do this year anyway I
take a five check yeah I think that Jack
should be actually quite good I get a
five and then the a born will be a force
time morning check check those nights
are pretty well coordinated actually
it's not that bad
check it's not made unfortunately I was
thinking ever made maybe but I don't
have one can I meet him here no I cannot
a stupid stupid stupid
oh I didn't spoil that that's such a
shame he really gave me that game very
simply and now I'm I have spoiled that I
have no night moves here ah what a shame
white resides Wow yeah I'm just totally
winning you completely nows else add
some ghosts of a check night there night
f7 something is made but I don't get
there it's still win skinny four wins
everything winds where it was just very
badly played yeah justjust hear do
something normal I have 50 seconds I
really need to stop giving away stupid
games like that I mean that that's
really just just totally stupid and this
is this is the easiest wind yeah it just
blocks that rook and this is promoting
what a big joke okay yeah it was very
strange that we should be three move i
mean i think this position is probably
probably equal complicated but this is I
mean I didn't understand any of that I
mean here first of all what you could
have done he could have very easily took
on taking only two I mean why not take
only two I don't see why I didn't do
that just get a second porn here it's
very simple no we didn't do that allowed
this and then then you stumbled into
into that f5 business after which yeah I
mean this is just just terrible for like
and gladly losing can yeah chat chat
agree an exceptional idiot sometimes not
if five chance really okay and then just
just put it only 20 it's over chan yeah
I know it is got F for him as a threat
it turns out it's still good for me but
now a bit complicated yeah this is now
complicated of course they had not sure
if I believe the compy f it is deep
enough yet to see what happens maybe up
and drew order to add raw edge
evaluation just seems kind of strange
yeah I don't know but while losing
losing is really utterly stupid ready
okay well thanks for watching